here's what would happen if you went  surfing on a tsunami the highest wave  ever surfed was 24.4 meters tall but our  tsunami wave would be even taller than  that at 30 meters to surf this kind of  wave you'd need to get your dumbest  friend to drive you to the top of it on  a jet ski while you hitched a ride on  the back  and if you managed to get to the top  you'd quickly realize that this tsunami  is different from any other wave you've  surfed a typical wave curves and  cascades making it easy for your  surfboard to grab onto but tsunamis  don't have this quality causing you to  lose your balance  and now it's time to hold on for your  dear life and hope for the best that's  because the tsunami would toss you  inland and the receding waves would  bring you right back out into the ocean  if you somehow manage to survive this  first wave well more are on the way a  tsunami can sometimes last for an entire  hour so